hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is caleb denby
and i will be your driver on this
journey
uh tonight i wanted to talk about uh the
king's indian defense again from the
white side but rather than continue the
the series which got put on a little bit
of a pause where i tried to refute that
opening uh ran into some roadblocks
there turns out the king's indian is
pretty good um tonight i wanted to talk
about a system that uh various nakobian
uh has used to great success for for
quite a long time now and it's going to
be uh not quite as as testing as forcing
as the lines i was recommending but i
thought it would be fun to look at this
system at a few different levels of
chess so to introduce the opening i'm
going to start with the man var okobian
himself
i'm going to go through
one of his games from quite a while back
i think 2005 just to introduce his
opening some of the ideas and what we're
going to be looking at tonight um and
there might be a surprise game uh in
store after this so stay tuned
uh but var of course starts with d4 we
get into the king's indian defense
following g6 knight c3
bishop g7 knight f3
and castles
so uh you're probably familiar with this
position this one happens all the time
and very very commonly white goes e4
and i was recommending those classical
lines where you go bishop e2 castles and
knight e1 and you get those fun exciting
games where black is racing to checkmate
you on the king's side you're trying to
checkmate black on the queen side and uh
it's it's a lot of fun
but var has for a long time played this
interesting move bishop to g5
so what do you guys think about this
move i
hate those little annotations on board i
get rid of them
uh what do you think about bishop g5
what's what's going on with this move
what could be the idea
yeah so we're often told that bishops
are long-range pieces and especially in
queen's pawn openings where you start
with with the d-pawn it makes sense uh
to develop this bishop kind of last
because this bishop is already pretty
active here it's it's aiming at a lot of
squares on this diagonal
and if it comes out to a square like
like g5 you're totally right in thinking
that hey this this bishop might get
harassed it's sort of an enemy territory
and it's gonna allow things like maybe
h6 or something later on to to gain some
tempe against this piece
so it is very much a counter-intuitive
move we're we're not used to seeing
white develop this bishop so early so
whenever you do something
counter-intuitive there normally is a
very
distinct idea behind it so var has this
really distinct idea
and that's the reason why i played
bishop g5
and the reason for that
is that after the move d6 he was
planning to play this move e3 the whole
time not going for these e4 systems but
instead playing e3 and his point is yeah
maybe i didn't want to go bishop g5 it
is counter-intuitive it's not natural
but if i want to play the move e3 i
really need my bishop outside the pawn
chain rather than inside the pawn chain
on c1 so that's why you see this move
bishop g5 but it's important to
understand you don't just play bishop g5
to develop the bishop play bishop g5
because you have this plan of playing e3
and you want the bishop outside the pawn
chain
um so black in this game does play d6
and we're going to be analyzing most
position uh tonight we're going to be
analyzing the positions that that occur
after d6 is worth noting uh i think uh
in bula gun's book he he recommends this
move c5 against this line
uh and then you get into some benoni
kind of structures after d5 you're still
going to play e3 a lot of the time
and it's just going to make for for an
interesting game black should be doing
okay
uh instead though we're gonna see d6 and
this is sort of by far the most common
move in the database and i'm gonna say
that white might actually end up with a
little bit of an advantage here
so to continue on we see this move e3
so
now we know why bishop g5 was played
white wanted to play e3 but this sort of
raises a new question why do we want our
pawn on e3 why not leave this pawn on e4
you know more space should be better so
why why e3 what's the big deal
what's the big deal here
the only thing i can think of is just
yeah so it's it's supporting this pawn
on d4
um but more importantly than that we're
gonna see that white is striving
to improve upon certain lines of the
king's indian defense where black ends
up making use of this d4 square so once
you go e4 you know there's the cliche
saying pawns don't move backwards
meaning once you move upon forward it
can never step back and defend those
squares that it was once able to defend
and what white is saying is that uh he
would rather have this pawn on e3 to
defend this d4 square and some critical
lines to give you an example of some of
those lines
let's put some moves on the board
specifically here
let's go ahead and yeah we can play d
take c5 right away well actually let's
let's castle
well
okay how do i want to get there
let's say the knight d7 lines and now d
takes e5 d takes e5 so this is an
example of a line that's actually not so
good for white
and the reason for that is black has
successfully made his claim on these
dark squares and in the very near future
you can expect to see knight c5 to e6 to
d4 once this knight lands on d4 it's
actually black who is very seriously uh
fighting for for big advantages um
alternatively very common is rookie 8
knight f8 96 knight d4 lots of ways to
to get to this um
d4 square
so what var is saying with this move e3
is that after e5 probably eventually
white is is planning to capture this
pawn
uh and then
um we're not going to play it here
obviously but the point is in those
similar lines black is not going to have
this d4 square available it's going to
be contested
and that is actually what var manages to
do in this game so let's see how he does
it so black plays knight b to d7
preparing e5 bishop e2 and black even
plays c6 and queen c7 to prepare this
move even further
um so in the meantime var gets his
pieces off the back row uses this queen
to support the e4 square
uses this bishop just to get developed
so you can castle think about defending
this knight coming out this way
we see castles and e5
so what do you think white should should
play in this position what should we do
here
keeping in mind the the point of our
play
point is we want to get improved
versions
of lines where the d4 square is
important
yeah so black just broke with this move
e5 and we're trying to find some way to
make use of this e3 pawn
yeah so pushing is one option and
there's many good moves here so let's
let's throw some out just get some ideas
and rook ad1 is very good
also very intuitive is maybe rook fd1
or just takes so these are the moves
that that we really need to decide
between here um
and
i'm not gonna lie i think most of these
are playable but one of these options i
think is a little bit less coherent with
with our plan
so i don't really like this idea of
playing the move d5 here
and the reason for that
is this pawn on e3 is now sort of
useless and our bishop is actually just
sort of out of out of place if we are
going to lock the center down anyways
why not have this pawn on e4 just
helping us support this d5 break you
know that just doesn't make sense with
our previous play
however supporting the center with a
rook to d1 is good and i also think that
taking right away on e5 is is very very
reasonable here because again our goal
is to get to these kinds of positions
where uh black's main plan of getting a
knight to d4 is just no longer feasible
uh in the game var did choose rook f to
d1
and after rook to e8 he goes ahead and
plays this move uh rick a to c1 ends as
well
and now i think black might have had an
opportunity to
steer the game closer towards equality
after this uh this next decision here
i think black started sort of started to
lose the grip on the position already
things started to get kind of nasty
so black to move here
and not fully equalize but
at least give himself
a good plan
okay so c5 is interesting
um but that's actually going to make our
plan even stronger i think
so the problem with c5 is the same
reason why is the same problem with e4
not that e4 in the opening is like a bad
move but the problem is it leaves
squares behind and that's what var is
hoping to avoid so with c5 i have no
doubt var would be planning to take e5
and again we're going to get this
position
now we have this square defended and
black does not have this square
defendant so white's just going to have
an easy easy advantage here it's all
about this square and in fact here
white might even be able to take it a
step further jump into to the next
square up
so c5 goes away too much we need these
squares under control
what do you think um
yeah so e takes d4 i think this is the
route that that black should have taken
um
now even here white's gonna be pretty
happy that this pawn is still on e3 with
the pawn on e4 sometimes you'll see this
knight come under fire with this bishop
on g7 so this pawn on e3 is still going
to be useful here but at the very least
black is going to have
squares to put the pieces on right black
is going to get developed maybe play for
a d5 break at some point and we'll at
least have some some ideas in the game i
do think white is still a little bit
better but i think that this was the way
that uh black should have tried to to
fight
um
if you tried this move e4 i think some
people in the chat were talking about
this
um i think you get into trouble right
away that's actually var has cleverly
placed his works very very well to deal
with this idea uh because now this pawn
is attacked three times and i think if
you go here we have um we have a pretty
nice tactic to win material immediately
so white to move in and win here
it's not
horribly complicated it's just uh
just a nasty tactic
yeah so i initially thought that this
might work but i think actually you sort
of trick yourself here i might have
misled you with the word tactic here i
think you run into trouble if you take
the queen back they take your knight
and if you take on f6 if knight takes f6
then this has worked out well for us but
yeah bishop takes and then this bishop
does prove to be a liability and that's
something you have to look out for this
bishop is overextended like we said
however i think white has a number of
really good moves here and actually
maybe we can reverse the order of our
idea and take on f6 first
so now no matter what takes be it knight
or bishop we can take on d5
now if queen takes takes
and if bishop takes still takes
and just to show what happens here if
you take the knight instead i am happy
to take on c7 i get my piece back i'm up
a pawn my rooks are horribly active and
uh this pawn is is going to be a bit
weak so we do win a pawn outright i
think white has other moves here as well
queen b3 is probably quite good knight
b5 is is probably quite good uh with a
threat of a fork just forcing all of
black's pieces to really awkward squares
can't be too too bad
and this would actually hang this pawn
maybe you even have to play like this
ugly ugly move
um but yeah probably bishop f6 here is
the simplest
um so pushing forward doesn't really
work black just gets overextended so i
do think that this was was the way to go
instead black opted to keep the tension
with knight to f8 and now var says okay
you had enough chances to take on d4 and
go for that kind of position um no he
doesn't he plays b4 first
okay so black could still go for this
idea of e takes d4 and maybe he should
uh but maybe he's already gone a step in
the wrong direction no longer has knight
c5 it's it's already sort of uh
sort of gone so instead bishop f5
queen to b3 and then black plays this
move knight to e4
um okay
so now it's white's turn again our next
move is
going to be pretty clear actually we
don't really want black to
capture our bishop so
and if we move it out of the way we
don't really want to draw one of our
major pieces onto the same diagonal as
this bishop
so white takes
takes
and then var goes ahead and takes on e5
so this is the idea that that we've been
angling towards
and var played all these preparatory
moves just to make sure he could get
a definite advantage after the capture
uh so once again i sort of blew by
things there so b4 the point of this is
is pretty clear we want to gain space on
the queen side and we'll see uh what his
intentions are but his intentions are to
make d takes c5 a better move with this
idea of b4
so okay we get here takes takes
and now var plays one more tempo move
with knight d2 forcing this bishop away
and now what was the point of of b4 uh
if you're familiar
with these kinds of positions
then you'll already know this idea
white's ideas are going to be the same
as in the positions where our pawn is on
e4 it's just that in this case we sort
of get a better version because we have
eliminated black's ideas so wait to move
here what's our plan
ah and the truth icc is in the chats a
good friend of mine from a long long
time ago
and he has the right idea
any ideas from the in-person crowd
what to do here
so
um really in all of these lines where d
e and d e gets played it's gonna be uh
the plans are going to be based around
the knights so that's why this e3 move
is so powerful black's night maneuver is
is just broken it just doesn't work we
busted it uh however white also has a
really strong night maneuver here black
also gets to say no i'm i'm the best
i've clamped down on both these squares
as well no knight d5 for you no knight
d4 for you
but white's going to find a different
square and that square of course is d6
so how do we get this knight to d6
yeah absolutely c5 and this is why var
had played b4 earlier on he was
preparing this idea of c5 sort of saw
this position coming wants to go here
um black tries knight to e6 hitting this
bishop we go bishop h4 and now it's it's
sort of really clear um just to show one
more time
just for example if we had this position
white's in major major trouble
major major trouble if we put this pawn
in e4 and undeveloped black's bishop
white is is really suffering here
because his knight is so so active and
the best that uh you're really going to
be able to do with the white pieces here
is hope you can trade this guy off and
give black a very powerful d4 pawn
supported by the bishop open up this
file for in this diagonal for black's
major pieces and white white is
definitely
on the back foot
however with this pawn on e3 we can go
c5 after knight e6 bishop h4 uh what's
the story you know what is what is the
point knight d4 just cannot be played
and that's that's really the power of of
this system
um okay but igor uh foigle whoever he
may be with the black pieces was a
pretty inventive guy he came up with
this nice move g5 bishop to g3 and now
what do you think his intentions were
with this knight he had some nasty ideas
since knight d4 is no longer available
he came up with the next best thing
yeah so black takes advantage of some
tactics here as people in the chat have
it
have to advance this knight can't go to
d4 so of course what's the other square
yes knight f4 as you say
as you say
uh and so what's the point the point is
of course if we take this knight for
free
um your bishop is trapped and also i'm
attacking your other bishop too so the
tactic works in like four different ways
so this knight is taboo but no need to
panic white just simply plays bishop
back to f1 always play bishop f1 someone
i think has said that before me
uh okay
so now we have this position black is
like yes i got my knight to f4 but the
fact of the matter is it's just not
nearly as powerful on f4 as it is on d4
d4 is the only open file on the board
that's where all the action is it's not
enough for it put some pressure on the
position but it's sort of dominated by
this bishop on f1 this bishop is very
comfortable back here on f1 can't really
be a assailed in any way
and this knight on f4 by the way is
always going to be vulnerable to e takes
f4 threats it's not a permanent home
right this tactic where my bishop is
trapped isn't going to last the entire
game eventually this knight will have to
move
so
uh black came up with this idea just
bishop back to e6
and here
uh we're gonna go queen to b1 stepping
out of it grandmasters hate putting
themselves into pins so just queen to be
one
now black's like okay all right i have
to do something i'll go f5
uh and here i think var missed a chance
to
be a lot lot better but he came up with
a good move anyways so we'll we'll give
him credit here he was still he still
had quite a nice advantage
uh the engine says that you can just
take this knight now um sometimes you
should take the hanging pieces
and at the end of the day black's gonna
take back we're gonna come to c4
and there's this nice line where we end
up with this incredible minor piece uh
compared to black's bishop and this is
just this is gonna be so so sad
instead var came up with this nice idea
of knight to c4 so very intuitive you
know maybe he didn't like the
simplifications after pawn takes knight
knight to c4 i like this move because it
sticks with our game plan it's a very
human way way to play
and finally black reveals their idea
they're like okay
uh my knight on f4 isn't actually doing
anything here i need to continue upon
storm with knight to d5 so black has
pretty nasty intentions again of going
to f4 and now i think this is
potentially one of the one of the one of
the better moves of the game i really
really like this move that var had in
mind so var of course saw this move
coming he saw that f4 was going to be
black's threat and from a distance he
had come up with this this nice concept
to
uh
to make its
just simply not work
so wait to move here and again
stop black's ideas
this move is just absolute disaster for
black
absolute disaster
okay you can go h3 and then you won't
lose your bishop for free
but this is
sort of what black wants black still
wants to go f4
and okay let's say you take
take bishop h2
we're really not happy back here we're
not so happy about all this um
even though we didn't lose our piece our
bishop is kind of bad back here for a
while and black is you know continuing
to roll getting all this space
so what white's move does is it stops
this pawn storm sort of entirely
and
pokes sort of
a ton of holes into
into black's position
it's not the only good move here i
should say but it is a very nice move
yeah so you you're looking for some way
to stop this f4 idea and so it's natural
to consider f4 yourself but we just
don't have enough firepower i think we
just we run a little short here
g takes e takes
black is is doing well
yeah bishop d3 black is is happy to to
give up this pawn we still get f f4
um so some people in the chat have it
the truth has it again
ah and josh my good friend josh is in
the chat i didn't see that
yeah josh unfortunately this is not a
continuation of the previous series this
is
a look into a cobian's approach against
the king's indian
we're not refuting tonight we're just
looking at a different approach
so knight to d6 by flame writer in the
chat is a good idea but this is also
sort of what black is hoping for i think
black kind of realizes at this point
position's a little bit tough and knight
to d6 is going to make things pretty
complicated
after f4
we do get to take a rook although i
would argue maybe this knight is worth
more than that rook
but at the end of the day our bishop's
still going to be trapped
so of course the idea as quite a number
of people have have said now is to go e4
and this is uh a fork
uh so this is the move that is total
total disaster for black why is this
move so so bad well if you take here
all of a sudden
every weakness in the black camp is just
sort of highlighted
accentuated there's there's nothing
nothing keeping all of these pawns
together the light squares are weak the
dark squares are weak once this f5 pawn
goes it's it's just death
and
if you try to move this knight out of
the way
of course i'm gonna be happy to do a
very similar thing like where i capture
on f5 and okay maybe you can can do this
um
and i haven't looked too far into this
but maybe we can just play bishop d3
and it's going to be a very very similar
story here you just have all these holes
in your position black cannot keep
everything together and our bishop which
was once in danger of being trapped is
now pressuring a very very very weak
pawn on e5
so e4 is the monster move
flamewriter is asking the right
questions now he says what about f4 as a
reply for black and that's exactly what
black has to do black can't allow these
these weaknesses to happen so black has
to try this idea of f4 you know you
attack my piece i attack your piece
uh so how does this move actually work
well var is going to take this knight
and now black would be losing if he
cashed in and took the bishop on g3 but
you shouldn't take things that can't run
away so we get pawn takes on on d5 as a
response by by black
now uh now though var has successfully
given up this this bishop we don't need
to save this guy anymore we're up a
piece so we can give this piece back
uh knight to d6 is vars continuation uh
you know and this was our plan from the
start
rook to f8 and now again
uh i think
the the best concept of the game from
var this next move isn't the the
shocking move but
var's next move telegraphs his plan and
his plan here is is quite nice
so you've sort of achieved what you set
out to achieve you got this knight to
the square it's on the monster square
it's on d6 uh but now now what you know
now we need to continue the game right
you don't just win because your knight
got to d6 yes it feels like you should
be a lot better but you still have to
prove it
black in the meantime
is building this monster center
and it's going to try to get some
activity down this down this f file
so
our task as always is to activate our
remaining pieces and keep an eye on on
black's plans so how can we activate our
pieces and limit black's potential here
i'd be very impressed if you guys come
up with this plan
because white could uh could find
himself in danger if you sort of
lollygag about in this position
so some people want to go bishop to d3
but again you're walking into black's
new newly found huge center you know why
do you play the king's indian to build a
big center with black
that was a joke
so yeah e4 is just just nasty so there's
another idea in the chat to go f3 first
to try and prepare this idea of bishop
to d3
maybe you can try this idea i am very
wary of of opening up this dark square
diagonal especially with our our dark
square bishop not being long for this
world
okay and the truth
the truth in the twitch chat is always
has the truth
so the biggest threat here is this
massive mobile pawn center and var
understands this he understands that
this knight is a huge huge asset so he
has a little bit of wiggle room for for
dealing with the center but he does have
to deal with this center otherwise if
these pawns get rolling it's it's going
to be disaster it's going to be disaster
so that's why uh
that's what the truth is focusing on how
how can we stop these pawns from rolling
down the board and also get our
remaining pieces into play
it doesn't seem so easy
you're losing me there
you want to move the knight
oh b5 you mean
that'd be f5 right
yeah
yeah so queen v3 pins this pawn which is
super useful but what's your idea after
queen b3
i'm just feeling like
if uh
yeah okay i mean so black is going to
take and we'll we'll take back probably
before we do anything but then let's
just say black plays some move like
queen d7
so the idea of queen d7 you know we are
defending the bishop just going to unpin
our pawn and then that's going to allow
us to play moves like e4 d4 we really
want to
you're so close you're very close so i'm
going to put queen b3 on the board
because this was played and it's the
best move so good idea there
so takes and takes was played
um
but now after rook a to d8 so it still
doesn't happen immediately but but what
is
white's intention how is white going to
break through
94
yeah i mean relying on these these
tactics of this pawn being pins like
black shouldn't really be be allowing
those tactics like we can unpin this
pawn we can eventually play move like
queen e7 queen d7
uh
this bishop's not going to be undefended
forever
exactly
so the glorious exchange sacrifice so
the truth had this in the chat um this
is var's idea he understands that uh
these two pawns are are very very
powerful but this might as knight is
just going to be an absolute monster if
we can get the rest of our pieces into
play like yes this knight looks amazing
it's pressuring b7 it's pressuring the
king's side it's blocking off black's
pieces but he's going to need some help
in order to break through and so how do
we break through here well the only real
way that we could find
to get past the center is to sacrifice a
little bit of material for it so rook
takes d5 the exchange sacrifice is what
var had in mind
so he does do some preparation for it
though he doesn't take right away
again grandmasters hate pinning
themselves could run into some trouble
here well actually not not that much
trouble but
uh first
whatever he plays rook c2 and rook c to
d2
black goes bishop to f6 and finally
the time is right var takes on d5 and
now he's he's crashing through into the
position for the low low cost of in
exchange for
uh a pawn
yes
well that was the
our idea of queen to b3 here so you
can't actually move either of these
pawns with this move so if you go d4
those bishops attacks if you go e4 we
can again take advantage of that with
this this pin on this bishop
um
so if black were threatening to play the
move d4 like if the move queen e7 had
been played here uh i'm pretty confident
var would would not let e4 happen i
think he would d4 happen i think he
would go ahead and sacrifice right right
away um
let's go ahead and ask the computer to
make sure i'm not crazy
um yeah rick takes d5 by by far the best
move here not lying to ya
um
so yeah it's all about pushing those
pawns you're right but they never got
the chance and then var says okay enough
is enough i'm going to go ahead and take
uh b6 is black's idea this rook is still
pinned so he doesn't need to take it
right away
var goes ahead defends his pawn unpins
his rook so now we get takes and takes
but the fact of the matter is this
position is is going to be very very sad
for uh
for black the worst has happened we have
this fractured structure
with all of these weaknesses the pawns
are weak the squares are weak the light
squares are horribly weak we have our
unopposed light square bishop and our
monster night it's it's more more than
enough to
sacrifice one one little exchange
and with that exchange we took away all
of black's counter play it's no longer
active ideas it's just black trying to
stop the onslaught of this knight and
pawn and the rest of the white piece is
flooding in so from here we get queen g7
bishop to d3 finally time to activate
bishop back to e7 trying to get rid of
this knight we say no thank you knight
f5
takes on e7 so little tactics there no
time to take the rook because the queen
and here the knight defends the rook
and we pick up a second pawn
and from here
var is a professional
the game doesn't last much longer black
goes ahead and resigns here king is just
too weak this pawn is just too strong
and the white king is is perfectly safe
with this structure uh so black resigned
after c6
uh just to kind of explain why
uh after this move i think even queen to
e4
already
it's just just checkmate right
just going to be checkmate in very very
short order
um
yeah okay very short order didn't quite
realize it was that short
um okay so questions about this game
this was a pretty nice game to introduce
why we do these these weird things why
we play bishop g5 and e3 right does
everybody understand that the purpose of
not playing e4 in this opening
okay just general questions
uh this was a king's indian defense so
we started with
d4 and black fiancee we go d4 c4 and
then we get here and rather than play
the main lines with e4 we're talking
about this idea of bishop g5 and e3
oh looks like we got a raid from
chesweep thank you thank you
i can't actually see that on my chat
tough
there's a good question in the chat that
says why bishop g5 and e3 to answer that
question you have to watch the last 40
minutes of lecture
that's what that's what the whole game
was about
okay so with that i want to take you to
a more fun game a much lower quality
game
my good friend alex who's teaching the
beginner's class right now uh dug up an
old notation book of his
uh and in that notation book he has a
game from
2011 i think when i was 12 years old
where i played against him in a
scholastics tournament we were
scholastic fiends back in the day and
apparently we've played a game in this
exact line so now we've seen what it's
like with uh the grand masters
now we're going to take a look at what
it's like
at a much much much lower level we'll
talk about how ideas that you've seen
can get confused when you're just first
starting to learn them and how you can
kind of adapt
to the position as they change as it
changes so we have the exact same
opening in this game uh at the time i
was rated 1400 this was 11 years ago and
alex was rated 1300
uh and we get this opening bishop g5
alex goes d6 i go e3
now i don't really have any memory of
this game so
i'm gonna say what i think i was
thinking but you know your guess is as
good as mine and here alex goes b6 so
what do you guys think about this move
he was the first to deviate from the
games that we've we've seen previously
what's going on with b6
yeah so he's trying to go bishop b7
maybe bishop a6 i don't know but it you
generally play this move when you want
to to bring your bishop out this way so
what do we think about uh about this id
idea
it's a pretty beginning so
so
uh i think the problem with this uh
can be shown in a different game uh
which if we had time i was gonna go over
but we're definitely not gonna have time
so like you said it's a little bit
weakening of the c6 square maybe but
more importantly than that it's
preparing a move so not only is it
preparing bishop to b7 but really this
move is uh preparing an eventual c5
right
so that is sort of the crux of the issue
here if black is eventually going to go
c5 and let's even say they go bishop b7
first
followed by c5
uh what is white gonna be doing against
c5 there's a couple options obviously
but
there's one move that's a lot more
intuitive than the rest
yeah d5 and then this sort of just
makes your position look silly right you
could have played c5 in this position
and white probably would play d5 i think
d5 is the best move and instead you've
spent two tempi to bring your pieces to
these squares and now you've played c5
white still goes d5
and
in
return for your efforts your bishop is
looking at uh a wall
and you've played b6 when in reality
probably you want to play b5 probably
you would rather do it in one tempo than
than two right instead of b6 b5 b5 in
one turn would would be better so this
idea of b6 i think is just very very
misguided very very much not a good idea
so i respond to this uh misguided idea
with a misguided idea so i play bishop
to d3 so what do you guys think of of
this move this bishop to d3 move
why is this move not so not so correct
it's not a terrible move by any means
white is doing fine of course but
yeah e4
yeah so
you said the best you can get out of it
is trying to get to this e4 square which
is sort of a huge problem right that's
why this move doesn't make a lot of
sense black has fianchettoed making this
uh diagonal sort of a non-starter it's
it's really tough to open up this
diagonal to counter play against black
and getting the e4 is
really not not feasible right that's
just
too many things are going to be
defending it you don't want to make all
those trades
so this bishop just belongs on e2 where
it can defend the knight and more
importantly also stay out of the way of
the the d file remember our our game
plan like let's just for example say
that the game went back into normal
territory here
we got e5
takes takes now all of a sudden our
bishop really looks silly on this square
it's walking into knight c5 threats it's
blocking the d file it's susceptible to
maybe an e4 tactic later on down the
line
uh and it's just in our way we would
much rather have this piece on e2 so
it's important to realize where your
pieces belong and why they belong there
so bishop e2 would have been a much
better move instead bishop d3 bishop b7
queen c2 is what i played
we got
knight b to d7
and now i play a terrible terrible move
so
like you were thinking i was like man
why did i put my bishop on d3 i guess i
was doing it to go to e4 so i played the
move knight to e4
uh and already black is is doing pretty
well here
uh so the big problem with benoni
structures is that black doesn't have
enough space however if you can trade
just one minor piece or in this case
even two minor pieces the binoni
structures feel a lot more comfortable
suddenly every piece you have has a
square so black to move here how can you
get a nice position
yeah so knight takes bishop ticks
yeah we can just take this guy okay so
queen takes makes a threat
yeah but we can go knight f6 maybe with
tempo right
let's just say i come back and now
what structure do we want
yeah you can play a move here to get a
very very good structure
yeah c5
and now these d5 ideas
not so comfortable anymore this bishop
is
is by far the best minor piece on the
board and black is is going to be very
very happy with how this game is going
now remember that position where we had
this position but there was a bishop on
b7 and a knight on b8 and black was
going to have a lot of work to do to
find squares for those pieces
no longer does does black have that that
issue he traded off those pieces and so
his remaining pieces are just just good
they're just good pieces
um
so that's why 94 is a bad move instead
my opponent plays rook to e8
i'm like okay
knight knight f to d2 i i had an idea i
guess
uh now my opponent plays c6 so it's not
hard to understand why this is a step in
the wrong direction right
i suppose maybe he was thinking i was
going to try d5 or maybe he was going to
try d5 but of course still the right way
to go is to go for these c5 structures
and potentially trade off some pieces on
e4 first
instead c6 i take on f6 and castle
finally
and then i go knight e4 again so again
every time i play 94 in this game it's a
terrible terrible move
this time
the problem again is going to be after
captures
and now black to move here and black is
is almost just strictly winning we have
some nice nice ideas
let this be a more cautionary tale for
people
looking to play this opening with whites
black to move here you're not going to
win a ton of pieces or anything but
you're going to get a very very good
position
no we don't we don't really want to
weaken our king's side too much our
king's side needs to to stay
stay as is
yeah we're we actually don't really need
e5 here anymore we uh this move c6 is
going to turn out to to come in handy i
sort of justified black's play
yeah d5 is is nasty
you actually cannot capture this pawn
because ticks makes two threats at the
same time
so you would have to come back
and then here it's no time to stop with
the black pieces the pressure's on
what's the follow-up
you could take um
i like uh this other move better though
yeah so as people in the chat are saying
c5 is really really good
maximum tension in the center
and now white is in a very very bad way
and i like showing these lines because
it really highlights how bad of a move
bishop g5 is so
i want to emphasize you you don't play
this opening because you get this nice
active bishop on g5 that puts all this
pressure on on black
you play this opening to
avoid making weaknesses and then aiming
for for those other lines where yes
you're going to spend some time getting
your bishop to a more reasonable square
you almost always are having to retreat
this bishop but you know you get these
other advantages
so here what's the big deal let's say
you take
i can even start with this
and white might just be losing heavy
material very very quickly with uh with
these kinds of ideas it's bishop's in no
man's land you're pinned down the c file
it's it's over it's over
so my opponent missed that opportunity
though and played
something else he didn't take on e4
so queen c7 instead
and now i'm back to being fine took on
f6 pawn takes f6 bishop f4
queen to d7
uh so now white is is back in control of
this game black sort of missed this
opportunity to to break free and
challenge the center uh for those kings
indian players looking for advice on
this game you can't delay challenging
the center forever that's sort of what
happened in this game i gave my opponent
every opportunity to break free c5 d5 e5
all of these moves were options at
various points but he just never did any
of them and if you never challenge the
center eventually center is going to be
useful
so after pawn takes attacking my bishop
i retreat that pinned the queen so the
queen moved out of the way
now
we find some way to get active here
and from this point on i played classic
scholastic 1400 level chess i just tried
to make a threat every turn until
something worked
but in this case turned out my threats
were kind of good moves
yeah steven just joining the chat so uh
our first game that we went over was was
about having this pawn on e3 and how
that can be a huge huge benefit so i
would
go back to the first game in the lecture
that's
that's what it's all about
so i played queen a4 i was like yeah
attack a pawn and maybe depend upon
maybe something happens right queen a4
actually i think is the best move so
what was the other move you suggested
though
e4 yeah i really i don't know if i if i
like this move uh black has this sort of
very compact structure over here
um and that's going to allow him to to
sort of guard these kinds of squares
very very well and i think e4 would be
asking for for something like d5 to come
on the board when all of a sudden you
know black's bishop which is you know
staring at this pawn might all of a
sudden be getting active you're again
going to see these d5 c5 type breaks
um
coming coming through and eventually
this bishop will wake up and attack your
d-pawn but yeah queen a4 is a very nice
move just attacks this this pawn and
after something like rook to a8 there's
a lot of ways we could continue we could
try
b4 we could try just bringing our rooks
to the center maybe even a move like d5
is worth considering uh maybe uh even
like queen a3 is is something to think
about as well so lots of options instead
alex played queen to d8 um trying to
trap my queen somehow but it just
doesn't work i took the free pawn
there's no rook a8 because this bishop's
attacked goes rook to e7 but i'm wise to
his tricks just back up with queen to a3
and now after c5
white is uh just winning this game and i
don't think i ever really looked back i
think i managed to keep keep this idea
okay
uh so the game continued with rook to f
to e1 kind of a weird move but i was not
that good at chess
uh queen to d7
rook a to b1 very weird move i think i
wanted to play b4 or something um
instead what should white be doing here
uh white should be finding some way to
uh make this this pawn advantage
uh
sort of both permanent and activate the
remaining pieces so how how could we go
about doing that in this position rookie
one was like okay fine but after queen
to d7
what do you think we should be aiming
for here
how do we go from up upon
to just winning the game
yeah
hillary in the chat has a good idea so
b4
yeah i mean b4 is going to add some some
complications to this game it might be a
very good move
uh but you might be allowing black to to
sort of continue to activate maybe
something like f5 all of a sudden maybe
you wish
you wish this pawn was on b2
anymore
um do you mean this one
no so that's that's going to give up
these these dark squares too much um we
thought about e4 in a different position
but it's a bit too weakening and black
is going to have some nice active ideas
in response
so
where is sort of the pressure in the
position for black black has some
pressure
against us right now there's sort of
some threats looming
black has some ideas
and we can resolve those those threats
here and just make it so black has to to
sort of sit back and let us do our thing
yeah d5 is is great here so all the the
pressure is coming from black targeting
our center threatening to open up these
dark squares and come attack us starting
to open up the c file as well so playing
d5 would be fantastic just shuts off
this bishop as well
cements this pawn on a bad backward
square and just
sort of removes the tension from the
position we're up upon we don't need
complexities we need to simplify
um and from there
um
you could do a lot of things i think
just simply queen to b3 putting pressure
here pushing a4 a5 and getting the rooks
into the game is is a good next step
okay instead i played some nonsense he
played some nonsense
i also played some nonsense
um played f5
and i sort of realized that i think my
moves were nonsense
and yeah so i go queen queen to b3
so f5 was pressuring down this diagonal
and now all of a sudden since i like
wasted all this time doing nothing my
opponent's very much back in the game he
goes c takes d4 highlighting the fact
that i'm pinned down the e file i had a
plan though i took here on b6
now my opponent comes up with this nice
move rook to e6
i play queen to b4 trying to unpin
threaten to resolve this tension here so
my opponent takes no he goes queen c6
first
uh subtle threat
bishop f1
takes
takes and now my opponent gets a little
bit too fancy for his own good plays
this move rook to e4
so white to move and win here
it's a very very nice position for for
white if we can just
stop the pressure stop the threats
of course in any end game we're going to
be doing very well we have these three
connected pawns on the queen side
this d6 pawn probably isn't going to
survive
the question is how how can we get there
how can we survive
live to see the day
well he might be trying to take our
bishop right
so we got to be got to be careful
but if he does capture
yeah maybe we do have some tactics there
actually that's sort of the the
the idea
so we want to get some pieces off and we
can actually do that by by force here
absolutely so i i don't know why but i i
find this move to be really funny um
black had two rooks on this open file i
had one rook and
black you know moves one of the rooks
but doesn't capture and then yeah all
four rooks get to share the same file
now
so what's the point the point is exactly
what you were thinking this rook on e8
is a little bit underdefended and if
takes we simply take on on e8
and so this sort of
just immediately gets rid of all these
threats that black was trying to have
black tried bishop to d4 to keep up the
pressure
but i can just trade we get rook takes
rick takes queen takes and now i just
take on d6 with the rooks off the board
my queen centralized i'm gonna be able
to defend my king
more than uh sufficiently here
the game actually ended pretty quickly
he went king g7 i went bishop to g3
he goes h5
and here uh kind of amazingly after
queen to f4 there's no way for black to
avoid this queen trade um there's just
no way you can't move the queen and
defend the bishop
so the queens came off and then this end
game is just hopeless three connected
past pawns is enough is enough
he went for the king and pawn end game
and white won pretty easily after a4
spawns of course cannot be captured
so
that was my 1400 level take on this
opening system uh back when i was
either 11 or 12 years old uh lots lots
of fun alex said it was the 2014 bowling
game oh it was 2014 okay i was way older
i was 15. how did i play this game when
i was 15.
oh man
all right well
uh still young enough i wasn't that good
at chess but uh hopefully you learned
some some good ideas here so again the
point of this game is to kind of
emphasize uh
how important is to understand the point
behind the opening so the point behind
bishop g5 and e3 isn't to have some
bishop on g5 and that's a good thing
it's to control these these weakened
squares okay so you don't need to do
crazy things if your opponent does
something you don't know you just need
to to play logical intuitive chess
understand why your pieces are where
they are and then you can play the
system well
okay any final questions for me before i
hand it off to our grandmaster in
residence
okay thank you all very much for joining
me here tonight then uh up next for the
final time maybe for a little bit maybe
we'll see him a little bit in august
grand master ilyanisnik will be up next
uh ending his stay as grand mastering
residents it's been great to have him be
sure to stay tuned for that lecture as
always my name is caleb denby this has
been the road 2000 i'll see you all next
week
[Music]
you